u.s sanctioned iranian fuel arrives in
lebanon brought overland from syria also
under american sanctions hezbollah which
arranged the shipment to help alleviate
the widespread fuel and diesel shortages
in the country sees this as victory
against the united states
we assume we have enough supplies for
september and october then we decide if
there is a need for a fifth a sixth and
a seventh ship
importing fuel from iran risks u.s
action under the current sanctions that
is why the iranian-backed lebanese armed
group says it chose to offload a report
in syria and bring the supplies through
illegal crossings so lebanon won't have
to deal with sanctions related
complications but politics was also at
play hezbollah has managed this current
crisis very well
by presenting itself as a party trying
to protect the human population in a
country
and this
role is really difficult to challenge or
even for the united states to oppose
the biden administration which considers
hezbollah a terrorist organization has
chosen not to respond some say it is
because of efforts to restart
negotiations with iran on a nuclear deal
lebanon is entangled in the regional
conflict and fuel is being used as a
political weapon hezbollah is being
accused of trying to expand iran's
influence here the response of the
united states has so far been muted but
it is supporting another alternative
despite sanctions on syria it is showing
flexibility to allow lebanon to import
natural gas from egypt and electricity
from jordan
this is part of daily life in lebanon
fuel is scarce and nearly bankrupt state
the lebanese government has not
commented on the deal to import fuel
from iran but experts say energy sources
from iran egypt and jordan are temporary
solutions that won't fulfill long-term
needs
we need to build new power plants we
need to resort to gas we need to invest
in renewables and we need to have a good
governance hezbollah is part of the
system hezbollah is not a reformist
entity that is willing to do reforms so
hezbollah is not doing anything in the
government or anything in the parliament
to solve the crisis of the
energy
for now hezbollah long accused of
exploiting the weakness of a state mired
in corruption is celebrating the
geopolitical implication of what appears
to be the pro-iran alliance's growing
power senator al jazeera beirut